[Musique]
et si le major je suis sur place
je suis humain je défaille
mais moi je m'ouvre au changement je
m'ouvre à l'amélioration n'y a rien que
je ne puisse faire
rien que je ne puisse savoir et rien que
je ne puisse être écouté ça s'il vous
plaît c'est ma fillette de 4 ans le
temps qu'elle a mis pour chanter cette
comptine elle a appris à parler
l'anglais couramment
il y à une boîte à écho ici quelqu'un
analyse le flux des données voyons qu'il
est digne d'une telle surveillance
j'accède au réseau de sécurité de
l'hôtel
ça y est 43e étage il faut que quelqu'un
contacter l'équipe du président il est
surveillé docteur ossements dites-moi ce
que nous pouvons faire pour vous je
crois que la question est qu'est-ce que
en cas robotics peut faire pour vous
aujourd'hui 73% de l'humanité s'est
adapté à l'ère de cyber améliorations
vous voulez vraiment être à la traîne
mon peuple s'ouvre aux cyber
amélioration autant que moi mais
personne n'est conscient des risques des
conséquences sur l'individualité
l'identité quand on commence à jouer
avec l'âme humaine
monsieur excusez moi je pense que oui
le couloir 6 hommes des coups de feu
section naf vous arrivez quand deux
minutes un jeu trop long j'interviens
votre discours mais familiers vos
concurrents blanc déjà servic es à
présent rencarde 6 mai le dépôt de ce
que voudrait sac est trop beau doublé
voilà de quoi je parle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chez moi s'il vous plaît on n'essaie pas
mourir qui t'envoient cheveux noirs s'il
vous plaît répond collaborer avec
encarts au beau fixe et vous aurez
détruit ghost in the shell le 29 mars au
cinéma
je t'ai observé il faut que tu te
souviennes j'ai vu quelqu'un à la mamba
ils n'étaient pas humains
c'est un criminel connu et il a tué à
nouveau il n'a pas fait que ça il acquit
leur cerveau
il est partout et nulle part je vais le
trouver et je vais le tuer
tu parles jamais ton passé je me
souviens pas grand chose que des bribes
il ya eu une attaque
tu allais mourir
nous avons sauvé et maintenant tu au
sort d'autres
tout ce qu'ils t'ont racontée est un
mensonge
tu avais une famille souviens toi de ça
qu'est ce que tu es
tu es belle
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux de moi
ils ne t'ont pas sauvé la vie il te
l'ont volé
il y en a eu combien de mois
il était prévu que son cerveau soit
vierge
détruisez là
majeur
ils m'ont créé mais ils ne peuvent pas
me contrôler
[Musique]
ils ne vous ont pas sauvé la vie
il vous l'ont volé
ici le majeur
je suis sur place
[Musique]
j'y vais
tu es la première de ta génération tu
n'es pas à vulnérable
peut-être que la prochaine fois vous
recevrez mieux
elle
tout le monde autour de moi ce sens
connectée à quelque chose
[Musique]
on était à quelque chose que moi je n'ai
pas qu'est ce que tu es
tu allais mourir
nous devons sauver et c'est au tour de
sauver les autres
ça
je ne sais pas à qui faire confiance à
moi tu fais confiance
à
je sais que j'ai un passé
je découvrirai qui j'étais
[Musique]
tout ce qu'ils vous ont dit était un
mensonge qui est faux
ils ne vous ont pas sauvé la vie ils
volent en vol
[Musique]
il y a eu une attaque
nous avons sauvé c'est un miracle non
c'est une arme
tout ce qu'ils t'ont racontée est un
mensonge qui est faux ils ne t'ont pas
sauvé la vie il te l'ont volé
je sais que j'ai un passé je découvrirai
qui j'étais ghost in the shell le 29
mars
[Musique]